democratic senator chris murphy visited
a border facility last week and he
tweeted
i fought back tears as a 13 year old
girl sobbed
uncontrollably explaining through a
translator how terrified she was
senator murphy joins us now for his
first tv interview since the visit which
did not include the media senator good
morning to you
it occurs to me that you and your
colleagues in congress are in effect our
eyes and ears right now the eyes and
ears of the american people so please
tell us as you held that young girl's
hand and she cried in front of you what
were you thinking and what were the
conditions like for the other children
there
well what i thought about was the
decision her family made to send her to
the united states
and how desperate things are in her home
country of guatemala this is a
humanitarian crisis
in countries like el salvador guatemala
mexico where the violence is so
epidemic that these children have to
take this harrowing journey to the
united states these families
know these kids are going to likely end
up in these detention facilities but for
them
that's better than facing certain death
or recruitment into
vicious drug gangs in their home
countries the conditions um
you know listen i wouldn't want you know
my children to be in those detention
facilities um but this isn't 2019.
these aren't cages uh there are doctors
and child care workers there and
the biden administration is trying to
you know deal with a mess they were left
from the trump administration the trump
administration effectively
dismantled the asylum system and so
biden is trying to stand it up as
quickly as he can
get these kids processed um so that they
can have a chance to make the case to
stay
in the united states senator murphy you
set up the choice there for families
quite well there's the danger in the
country where they're coming from and
then there's these facilities here in
the u.s
the administration is saying the border
is closed but clearly the border is
open for people under the age of 18 and
for some
families can you see how that might
encourage more people to come and
deepening of this crisis
well there's no doubt that there are
human smugglers
that are lying to families in mexico and
central america telling them
that they can come to the united states
now um
i think it's important for secretary
marcus and others to make clear that
with the exception of unaccompanied
minors
uh everyone else gets turned around but
let's be clear the policy we're applying
to kids right
now is the policy we applied to everyone
prior to covid even under donald trump
before
early 2020 if you were an adult a family
or a minor and you presented yourself at
the border and had a claim for asylum
you were allowed to stay and make that
claim through the court system
so the policy right now that is in place
for
unaccompanied minors is the exact same
policy that applied to every single
migrant
even under donald trump prior to 2020
nothing is new
here the border is not open but for
these select young children um it's just
not right to
turn them around and send them back into
dangerous northern mexico by themselves
we you know as a compassionate humane
country
need to take care of them and protect
them yeah senator people can understand
from a humanitarian point of view that
argument but your critics will point out
and critics of the administration will
point out
that by letting in as you put it select
young people but really all young people
that does encourage more to come and
when the smugglers say you can get in to
a person under the age of 18
they're not lying well but but again the
point i'm making is that
this is the law right this is the law
that donald trump was applying
the only change is that when covid hit
um
there is a provision of the immigration
statute that for a temporary amount of
time during a public health emergency
allows you to turn everybody back around
um
so the law says uh that absent that
emergency
the united states has to give people who
are showing up at our border a chance to
apply for
asylum and listen we are a compassionate
humane
country if these people really are
facing death
if they go back home we should give them
a chance to
to stay at least for now um these
children remember 50
of these children don't actually pass
the asylum bar they actually do
eventually get turned around and sent
back home
senator we're running out of time but i
want to ask you what hope is there from
where you're sitting for a bipartisan
solution
in congress to address this issue
my worry is that republicans see this
right now as a political wedge to try to
hurt the president
and drive down his very high approval
ratings they don't really want to talk
about the current
real crisis in america which is covid
and the battered economy um president
biden is
um doing some pretty amazing things to
get us back on
the right footing with respect to our
economic troubles
republicans don't want to talk about
that so they want to talk about the
border
i went there with a couple republicans
who are serious legislators rob portman
and shelly capito
my hope is that there's going to be
enough republicans in the senate that we
might be able to start to have a
conversation about fixing our broken
laws
all right we'll have to leave it there
senator chris murphy thank you very much